all the black ties and beautiful gowns
upstage Saturday night when the
entertainer at the annual White House
Correspondents Association dinner turned
in a blistering performance that got a
lot of attention and reaction Fox News
media analysts and hosts of Fox's media
buzz Howard Kurtz with all of the hubbub
the backlash is building against the
White House Correspondents Association
after what is widely viewed as a debacle
at its annual dinner President Trump
tweeted today the dinner is dead and
many journalists are insisting the
organization apologized for the harshly
personal attacks by comedian Michelle
wolf against such target says Sarah
Huckabee Sanders Kellyanne Conway and
Mike Pence
I actually really like Sarah I think
she's very resourceful like she burns
facts and then she uses that Ash to
create a perfect smoky eye if a tree
falls in the woods how do we get
Kellyanne and under that tree
suggesting she gets hurt just he thinks
abortion is murder which first of all
don't knock it till you try it maybe do
try it really knock it you know you
gotta get that baby out of there and
there were raunchy jokes about the
president sex life and a bunker trump
and tampons plus f bombs carried live on
cable
Bloomberg's margaret olive who heads the
association is refusing to apologize
saying in a statement today that
unfortunately Wolf's monologue didn't
match the dinners unifying tone of
support for a free press the fiasco was
a political gift for President Trump who
attacked dishonest journalists that same
night at a Michigan rally sources the
sources don't exist in many cases I
could be up there tonight smiling like I
love where they're hitting you shot
after shot these people they hate ya
guts the dinner intended to raise money
for scholarships has been under fire for
years since it became a celebrity
studded affair that seemed more about
cavorting with movie stars than
celebrating journalism other comedians
from Don Imus to Stephen Colbert have
generated controversy but this time the
dinners future or at least its format is
in doubt there's some selective outrage
here by Trump supporters who aren't
bothered by his personal attacks and
insults and by Trump detractors who are
making excuses for Michelle Wolf's crude
jokes but there's no dispute this is a
big black eye for the washington press
corps brett how are we thanks